فلاديمير فلاديميروفيتش بوتين الليلة
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يسخر من الولايات المتحدة يمزح حول
التدخل في الانتخابات الرئاسية
ويقول إنه سيفعل ذلك مرة أخرى
، سأقول لك سرًا نعم بالطبع
سنفعل ذلك لنجعلك أكثر سعادة في النهاية ،
فقط لا تفعل ذلك.  لن تخبر أي شخص أن
بوتين يدعم مطالب البعض
في واشنطن لرؤية المزيد
من النصوص لتفاعلات الرئيس دونالد ترامب
مع قادة العالم الآخرين بما في ذلك
قمة بوتين في هلسنكي العام الماضي عندما
كانت هناك محاولات لإطلاق فضيحة
بخصوص اجتماعي مع ترامب في
هلسنكي نحن مباشرة  أخبر
الإدارة أن تنشرها فقط إذا
أراد شخص ما أن يعرف شيئًا ما فقط
نشره ، لا مانع لدينا ، لكن فلاديمير
بوتين أيضًا زعمت أن نقاط حديث الرئيس ترامب في
المكالمة الهاتفية الأوكرانية سيئة السمعة ، بدأوا
إجراءات العزل هذه وطرحوا دائمًا
فريق نيكسون  كان يتنصت
على منافسيهم ، لكن هذا وضع مختلف تمامًا ، حيث
تم التنصت على ترامب
لبعض المجهولين  سرب موظف الخدمة الخاصة في وكالة المخابرات الأمريكية
هذه المعلومات وبناءً على
ما نعرفه من المكالمة ، لم
يكن هناك خطأ هناك ، حيث طلب ترامب من
زميله التحقيق في
مخططات الفساد المحتملة للإدارات السابقة